[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hi, and welcome
to episode 185 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I know we
can't do the Mark and Mark joke
for an eighth time in a row.
But how are you doing, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
very well, Mark.
[LAUGHS] I'm doing pretty well.
It looks like you and Michelle
had a really great interview
this week talking to
Scotiabank, I believe it was.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Absolutely, yeah.
We talked with our friend,
Yuri, from Scotiabank,
and talked a little bit about
some of the more interesting
paths to creating
a migration plan,
talking especially
about how Scotiabank
was able to bring GCP into it.
So I'm super excited to
get into that content.
But before we go into
the main content,
let's talk a little bit about
our question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so I'm asking
the tough questions this week.
We've mentioned in Cloud Shell
a few times on the podcast,
mainly because it's amazing.
But we're asking
the question of,
what if I want to add extra
tooling to the default Cloud
Shell image?
Maybe I want to
install something
like Helm or Terraform.
I use that on a regular basis.
But that's not installed by
default. So what can I do?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
it's like, how do you
make the amazing Cloud
Shell even more amazing?
MARK MANDEL: If such a thing
were possible, can you do it?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, you will
find out in just a little bit.
But before we get
even into that,
let's talk about our
cool things of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
What do you got?
I know you got some cool stuff.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
So the first cool thing
I have of the week
is Deep Learning
Containers, which
first of all, sounds fancy.
MARK MANDEL: It does.
It sounds very fancy.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
more than just fancy, it's
also super cool.
So these are in beta right now.
And it's this great way to
create a consistent environment
for working with machine
learning products.
So these Deep Learning
Containers are preconfigured.
And they come with all
these different tools
like PyTorch and TensorFlow and
all these different frameworks.
And they create a nice, stable
place to do your work from.
Because when you're working
with machine learning,
a lot of what probably
what you want to focus on
is the actual models and
training them and making sure
that they're working the
way you want them to,
rather than spinning up these
different environments and then
when you-- gosh, when you
have to migrate to the cloud,
you've got to worry about
what that environment--
it's just-- it's too much.
So these Deep
Learning Containers
are a great way to create
a baseline container
to work with.
And they have a
preconfigured environment.
So you'd get one up and running
locally, work directly on it,
then when it's time to
scale or go to production
or go out to the
cloud, all of those
are much easier because you're
using the same container
across the board.
MARK MANDEL: Another example of
the immutability of containers
being super, super handy.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
I mean, it's just like--
it's like containers
are everywhere or something.
MARK MANDEL: It's like they
took off [? some hell. ?]
[CANNED LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
Speaking of machine
learning, there's
a really great article
talking about how
to implement docking
and tagging with AutoML.
You can apply machine
learning algorithms
to document tagging-- that may
be something you want to do.
And you could potentially also
use some of the out-of-the-box
tooling that we have at Google
Cloud as well, something like,
say, the Vision API, or
potentially our natural
language processing platforms.
But it's quite
likely that you have
your own vocabulary for
your business domain,
or maybe diagramming or
particular recognition things
that you need to have happen.
If you don't want to go down the
full path of writing your own
custom machine learning models,
this article talks about how
you can use AutoML
Vision object detection,
as well as AutoML Natural
Language to basically train
these models in a much more
efficient environment--
at least, maybe that's
the right word--
or an environment where you
don't have to do as much
work to be able to have these
custom domain-specific types
of tagging abilities available
to you in an efficient way.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So it's a great way
to build your own machine
learning model without having
to write the code, right?
That's kind of what AutoML is.
You know, here's another
practical application of it,
and kind of a very
cool way to have
a wide variety of solutions
to solve whatever problems out
there.
Because sometimes it might
take just the standard APIs.
Sometimes you might have
to build another model.
But heck, if you need
to use your own code,
why not use a Deep
Learning Container?
MARK MANDEL: [CHUCKLES] Exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I don't
think it counts as a callback
if it was only 15 seconds ago.
MARK MANDEL: I think it does.
I think it does.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
But I'll call it one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I think it does.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, very much
in that vein, a little bit
more about machine learning
is this really cool integration
between BigQuery and Kaggle.
So if you don't
know about Kaggle,
it's this awesome
community where
there's a lot of data scientists
and other people in that field
working on creating and sharing
a bunch of machine learning,
either tips and resources
and labs and notebooks
and all kinds of things, right?
So it's this awesome community.
And they also have a
product called Kernels, so
Kaggle Kernels, which is hosted
Jupyter Notebook environment.
Well, if you have a
notebook out there
and you want to use Kernels,
you can very, very easily
go into the actual notebook.
And now you can just
call BigQuery right
from that environment.
So you can make a query.
You can write a query against
your BigQuery data set,
get the results back, and then
keep going in your notebook
analysis.
If you want to hear a little
bit more about what Kaggle is,
go check out episode 84 of the
Google Cloud Platform Podcast
when we talked a little bit
more about why Kaggle is so cool
and all the different kinds
of people and resources
that are there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that's a great episode.
Kaggle is an amazing
community of people
working on very interesting
machine learning problems.
So if you want to get
involved in that community,
I highly recommend it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
it's a cool place.
And with BigQuery
integrated into Kernels,
it's just going to make
it that much more easy
to see really cool insights.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And finally, it wouldn't
be a GCP podcast
if I didn't mention Kubernetes
in some way, shape, or form.
[CHIMES]
So we did just recently
introduce a new Jenkins GKE
plugin.
So if you're familiar
with Jenkins,
it is a very widely used tool
for automating software build,
test, and deployment, so
your CI and CD pipelines.
And we just released
a plugin for it
to make it easy to push
deployments out to GKE.
This is a super
nice plugin in that
you can make it super easy
to just push out deployments.
But not only does
it do deployments,
it will also do validation
for you as well.
So for example, with
the deployment manifest,
it will go and make sure
that the right number
of healthy Pods matches the
requested minimum that's
been requested as well.
This works for a
really nice GUI system.
But you can also use it with
the Jenkins Pipeline syntax.
So you can do some more
complicated stuff as well.
So yeah, Jenkins has been
around for a really long time.
But super glad to see us
supporting it even more.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, so if you've
got a big CI/CD pipeline
built in Jenkins,
you now have the ability
to easily integrate
with Kubernetes and actually
make sure that everything
you're pushing out is working.
Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool indeed.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's
some cool things of the week.
Let's get right into
our content with Yuri.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE CASBON: Welcome.
Today, we have a
very exciting guest.
We have Yuri Litvinovich
with us from Scotiabank.
I'm Michelle Casbon.
I'm here with Mark Mirchandani.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hello.
MICHELLE CASBON: Thank you
for joining us, everyone.
Yuri, it's great
to have you here.
Where are you joining
us from today?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Hey.
It's great to be
there at the podcast.
And I'm joining you
from Toronto, Canada,
the heart of the
North and the hometown
of Toronto Raptors, who
recently won NBA championship.
And that's the first
time in history
where the title goes
north of the border.
So we're all excited here,
there's lots of cheerful spirit
in the air, and lots of
smiling people on the streets.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And of course, we're
joining you from the exact other
side of that competition, San
Francisco and the
Golden State, where
people are thrilled that
the games were really good.
That last minute on--
what was that, game 6?
It was a real
nail-biter because--
I mean, I'm not even
a basketball fan.
But even I had to
peek at that and just
see it like, oh,
because it was 1 point.
Like, [POOF] so good.
But obviously, it was some
really awesome matches.
So I think everyone was
super excited to be,
like, well, it was a really,
really tough final fight.
And the Raptors deserve it.
MICHELLE CASBON: And
we're still friends.
We're still talking.
YURI LITVINOVICH: Absolutely.
We will always be.
And I'm glad that we have such
great teams and players who
can deliver so
much energy to all
of the people who watch them.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
So, enough about basketball.
Not that we couldn't probably
have a separate podcast on it.
But Yuri, why don't you tell
us a little bit about yourself
and what you do?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Sure.
So as I've been introduced,
my name is Yuri Litvinovich.
And I'm working as a Senior
Cloud Engineer for Scotiabank.
And I'm also Kubernetes
Tech Lead on the team.
So I've been with
IT for pretty much
all my life, starting as system
administrator and network
administrator, and
then slowly going
towards more of modern ways
of building applications
and infrastructure,
more toward DevOps.
And eventually, I transitioned
towards being a cloud guy.
And right now, I
work for Scotiabank.
And I'm part of the
organization called PLATO,
or Platform Organization.
And we are the team
that performs enterprise
modernization to transform
the bank into how we see that
into a modern technology
company in financial services.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yuri,
I think that background
is really important
because you've really
seen the depth and the
breadth of the industry.
So you start out on the
administration side,
networking.
And I take it that you were
in on-prem data centers.
And now you sort of followed
the evolution into the cloud.
So how have you
seen things change
as you've made that transition?
What have been the things that
have stood out the most to you?
YURI LITVINOVICH: And if
you go through all the years
and see the actual progress
that happened on IT side
and including on the cloud
side, it's just mind-blowing.
If you look at the all ways of
how people provisioned their,
let's say, servers
in the data center,
how they need to
plan in advance,
go talk to data center
teams to get rack space,
to get it all wired, connected--
and that just took
so much time--
to modern ways where you can
use the power of public cloud
and get your VM in
less than a second.
And it's fully there.
It's fully up and running.
And it's super highly valuable.
It's resilient.
It costs less.
It's just mind-blowing to me.
And I'm happy to be
part of this journey
and happy to live in
such exciting times.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
we've essentially
replaced a whole
class of problems
with a whole new
set of problems.
So if you're not facing
those challenges anymore,
what are the new challenges
that you've been facing?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
With this public cloud
that came to the market and
into the game, that provoked
big organizations like
Scotiabank to perform
digital transformations
because everybody understood,
including our leaderships,
that in this new world
where Cloud is pretty
much the only way forward,
we need to modernize
existing stuff.
And for example,
Scotiabank-- it's
a huge organization with
more than 90,000 people
in many different countries.
And we have 5,000-plus apps.
And most of these
apps were built
using old ways, historical
ways of building
applications for infrastructure
that relies on prem.
And transition to the cloud--
that is a big of an effort.
And this is what our
organization is doing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I want to hear more about the--
obviously, the cloud
details in a second.
But I think you
kind of just touched
on a really interesting point.
This is a big organization with
a tremendous amount of people,
a tremendous amount of
infrastructure and apps
and tooling built around those.
You know, it's a
complicated sector.
There's a ton of big
enterprises here, a lot of which
have legacy infrastructure
and architecture from past 30,
40, 50 years, that all of them
are facing the same problem.
How has that journey
been for Scotiabank?
Like, you said the
leadership was on board.
Traditionally, that's actually
not the most-- you know,
it's not the most
forefront thing.
You don't always see
a big push to do that.
So I'm really
interested in hearing
about how the company
has taken that response,
and how has it been so far?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Yes,
that's a very good question.
And let me share a quote
that our CEO, Brian Porter,
set in 2016.
He said that, "We are in
the technology business.
Our product happens
to be banking,
but largely that's delivered
through technology."
Basically, that means
that he set that direction
to go towards the cloud.
And that started the whole
chain of modernization
that went from top to bottom.
And of course, funds
were allocated.
We got all the talent necessary.
And the journey started for
us about three years ago
with going towards
building a platform that
would help developers to
accelerate their application
delivery cycles.
MICHELLE CASBON: I think
that's really important
to have support like
that coming from the top.
That means that
you're not having
to advocate for modernization.
That means that from
a business standpoint,
it's seen as something
that leaders are behind.
I think that improves
things significantly.
Is that different
from what you've
experienced at other companies?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Definitely big
organizations and enterprises
like Scotiabank need that
push from top to bottom
because traditionally,
financial sector enterprises
are more conservative than
the rest of the industry.
And it's totally fair and
understandable because there
is lots to protect and
be conservative about.
Scotiabank keeps PII
data for millions
of people, our customers.
And if anything happens,
their lives might be at risk.
All the money, let's
say, that people
gather for their entire
lives might be at risk.
So security is definitely
a big component.
And that, I believe,
is what differs
large enterprises in financial
services like Scotiabank
from startups, let's say.
Being a huge enterprise
in financial services
like Scotiabank, we are
responsible for providing
secure transformation because
many of our customers--
they rely on us.
They rely on that change
being uninterrupted to them.
So clearly, having the
push from top leadership
is very important.
And that gives engineers green
light to do transformation
and to make sure that this
transformation will end up
in success because
everyone is aligned.
While in smaller
organization, it's much easier
to bring bottom to top
change because it's easier
to pivot for them.
This is something that
I found in my journey
with both startups and
larger enterprises.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
I mean, we work with a
lot of companies out here.
And of course, in the Bay Area,
startups are pretty prevalent.
So it's kind of easy to think
about, oh, you can kind of just
influence change by making
a good case for something.
Well, that works really
well when your company
is 10 to 20 people large.
Turns out 90,000's a little
harder to move as quickly.
YURI LITVINOVICH: [LAUGHS]
You got it, exactly.
And you know what?
I see that's a very
natural thing that
happens even in the world.
For example, in
physics, we all know
that objects that
have higher mass
need more force, more
effort, to pivot or change
direction or change velocity.
Same happens with organization.
The bigger the organization
is, the more effort
it takes to actually
pivot and transform it.
So it looks very,
very natural to me.
And it's just the way it works.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, I think
that's been very noticeable
for me.
So I didn't join a startup
until a few years ago.
And the first
decade of my career
was spent in large enterprises.
And I think it has less
to do with the size,
like the number of
employees, and more
to do with the size
of the legacy software
that you're supporting.
And so, Yuri, talked
about having thousands
of applications that were
created in this older
architectural style.
Those applications
weren't written overnight,
which means that you're looking
at decades worth of software
that you're supporting.
YURI LITVINOVICH: Absolutely.
MICHELLE CASBON:
And so my question
to you is, how are you going
about modernizing those?
Is this why you chose
Kubernetes as a way
to be able to modernize
all of it at once?
Or are you looking
at it piecemeal,
maybe technology type
by technology type,
or architecture type
by architecture type?
What's your approach
been in modernizing
that amount of legacy software?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Yeah, definitely we
saw the trend that
the modernization--
one of the pieces
of modernization
is going towards containers.
And whole industry
goes toward containers
with all the benefits
that it brings,
including lightweight and
homogeneity during different
environments in dev,
in staging, in prod.
It's easier to test.
It's easier to roll out.
So we decided to build a
container orchestration
platform to help our
developers manage
the lifecycle of their
applications deployed
in containers.
And the very natural fit for
that container orchestration
platform was Kubernetes.
It pretty much became
an industry standard
for this type of work.
And Google, our great partner
in the digital transformation
journey, has an offering of
Google Container Engine, which
is a managed
Kubernetes solution.
So we decided to
build a platform based
on that, at least the
first iterations of it,
and basically provide
everything that it
brings to our end developers.
MICHELLE CASBON: So what
made you decide on GKE?
So I know that before
I joined Google,
I was in a similar
place to you where
I was looking at building
a platform to support
containerized deployments.
And I chose GKE, but I
was at a small startup.
So series A type, 20, 30 people.
So I'm very interested in
what your motivation was
in choosing a managed Kubernetes
platform, and also why GKE,
and why not a managed platform
from another provider?
YURI LITVINOVICH: We
decided to start with GKE
for a number of reasons.
And the first
reason is that we're
happy with what
GCP as a platform
brings to us at the bank.
It helped us solve many
different business challenges
and problems.
It's working well, and
our usage is increasing.
And GKE was the managed
Kubernetes solution.
And I know that Kubernetes--
raw, open-source Kubernetes--
it takes quite a bit of effort
to configure, to manage.
It takes quite a bit of
effort to make it work.
While the managed
solution from Google,
having a very modest price for
using that, brings lots of,
lots of things that
otherwise needed
to be developed on our own.
So it was kind of
a natural thing
to try and build our
platform based on the managed
solution from Google.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK.
And what are some
of the other aspects
of the platform that you
like in addition to GKE?
Does it play nicely with
some of the other services
that you use?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Yeah, totally.
And our goal would be to
build a self-serve platform
for our developers
that makes it scalable.
And this is just the
way to go, we believe.
So having GKE Kubernetes
running on Google
will help to integrate
it with existing services
that we use from Google,
starting from compute instances
and custom applications
running there, and ending up
with managed services like Cloud
SQL or BigQuery or Dataflow
or Pub/Sub.
They're all supported
by Stackdriver Logging
and Monitoring, which is just
a vital part of the whole GCP.
That just brought so much
power into our hands.
And eventually, that helped us
deliver that to our customers.
The same cool
infrastructure that
supports GKE and all other
services-- we will just
make our developers
use it and have
all the advantages of that.
MICHELLE CASBON: So it
sounds like you really
gravitated towards the
managed side of things
rather than rolling your own.
Is that a new
approach, or is that
pretty fundamental
to Scotia's DNA?
Has that been a change for you?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
OK, I think we're
focused here more on
managed sides of things,
but it's actually both.
In large enterprises
like Scotiabank,
we've found out that
it's just really not
feasible to bring
something to the plate
and not consider
existing infrastructure,
not consider existing stuff,
not consider teams that
were building their, let's say,
applications or infrastructure
for the last 20 years.
So we actually integrate
that new platform
with a bunch of
existing services.
And I believe that was
one of the big points why
the whole program
was such a success
and it's getting more
attention within the bank.
One of the reasons was because
we developed that relationship
with the existing services.
And we helped them to
modernize their stuff
without any hostility of--
with you guys are
old, and we are new.
We are helping them to get
all the benefits of Cloud
and doing that with
their own pace.
Let's say they
want to slowly move
some workloads to the cloud.
Sure, it's totally use case.
It's fair.
And we help them to do that.
If some people
want to go all in,
we have applications like that.
Cloud is also
available for that.
So definitely on top of
having that managed services
from Google Cloud Platform, we
build a lot of stuff around it
to make it usable for
the bank and to make
it compatible with existing
security processes,
with existing operational
readiness processes.
And that's what made
quite a success.
MICHELLE CASBON: So it sounds
like you had the flexibility
that you needed to
choose manage services
where it made sense, but not
in a way that forced people
to use them.
So you focused on building
a self-service platform that
empowered people without
strong-arming them
or having to these
blanket policies
for this entire giant
organization to follow.
YURI LITVINOVICH: Right, right.
Definitely.
And that is being
accepted very positively
because people understand
that we are there to help.
We're there to help them
solve their business
problems with less resources,
with more cost efficient,
with better technology, and
is definitely considered
a very positive change.
So people co-create with us.
And this is something
that we value.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
when working with all
these different teams--
I mean, you've kind of alluded
to the different parts of GCP
that you use to make their
migration a lot easier.
What's been your favorite
part or the part that
has been the most helpful in
convincing a lot of these teams
that that migration is possible?
YURI LITVINOVICH: One
of the best benefits
that you can get by
going to public cloud
is not only cost
efficiency, but a bunch
of things that are traditionally
very hard to achieve.
For example, it's
instant provisioning.
You don't need to
wait for hardware
to be ordered and
set up and configured
and then ready for you.
I would say dynamic
provisioning is a great one
as well because we only
pay for what we use.
And when you don't
need it, you can
configure Cloud and
services around it
to automatically scale
down and take care of that.
And of course, the resources are
nearly unlimited in the cloud.
You don't have to worry about
you running out of disk space,
let's say, or running
out of compute power.
Just get more instances.
Just get more storage.
And I also believe that
Cloud can provide you
with more enhanced
security than what
you can achieve on your own.
Because cloud providers--
they can afford--
have thousands of security
architects and specialists
that can reach the
level of security
that hardly even the
big organizations
can afford if they have
their dedicated teams.
So if properly
engineered, public cloud
[? can ?] be made safer
than your own dedicated
infrastructure.
And you don't pay any upfront
costs on using the cloud.
As I said, you pay
for only you use.
And this has a lot of
benefits and convincing points
for them to start
that modernization
and join this
transformation happening.
MICHELLE CASBON: And
that's really interesting
to hear you highlight enhanced
security as a benefit of cloud
because I think a lot
of people traditionally
are scared of cloud because they
perceive it to be less secure.
Could you just
share maybe a couple
of your favorite security
enhancements, or just some tips
for people who are looking to
make their apps more secure?
What have you found most useful?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Right, so
one of the first and grounding
and the very base thing that
GCP offers is total encryption.
Everything is encrypted at REST.
Encryption [? is ?]
[? intrinsic ?] [? is ?] there.
So it's very hard for
some malicious individual,
let's say, in a data
center, who are secure too,
get any information, even if
they have access to hardware.
So another great thing that
you can achieve with Cloud
is having your
environments configured
in a very similar way.
And here is a great
use case for Anthos,
the new thing that
Google introduced quite
recently at Next this year.
This can be used as a powerful
configuration management
tool that can span not only for
GKE, but also for GKE On-Prem.
And I believe there are
plans to support other cloud
providers like Amazon or Azure.
And having that
one central place
where you control your
configuration and security
and other things is
just a no-brainer
that this is more
secure than when
you have multiple environments
and maybe multiple people
responsible for configuring
each environment.
I would say this is one of
the good points of having
that enhanced security
that comes with Cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So with all
of the security in the cloud
and all these other
advantages that you've
been able to convince
your teams of, hey,
these are good
reasons to migrate,
I'm also interested in
hearing what their number one
concern was to not migrate.
So what kind of
pushback have you
been getting from all
of these instances that
have been challenging for you?
Because obviously, there are
going to be a lot of issues
when planning a migration.
YURI LITVINOVICH: I believe one
of the challenges that we've
encountered was trying
to convince them
that having to modernize
their application
is the effort that
they need to perform
and it will benefit them.
Because going to
Cloud, we promote
when you actually modernize
your application, right?
You don't just lift and shift.
Otherwise, Cloud becomes
just another data center
for you, just in a
different location.
We really promote you to build
your application using all
the DevOps principles in mind.
And that's required
a bit of work.
So I believe one
of the challenges
that sometimes we have
with application team
is to actually show them
that Cloud is faster,
it's more cost effective, and
it will deliver value faster.
But I would say those are the
early days of the program, when
the thing was just
introduced to Scotiabank
and no one really heard
about doing public cloud
for financial services.
Everyone was like, OK,
cool, another new feature
or something.
But slowly, gradually,
we build the trust
by having success stories from
other application teams that
took a risk allocating
resources to actually do
the modernization
and go to the cloud.
And once application teams see
the velocity that it brings--
so for example, used to take
six months for some applications
and teams to get
their data centers
set up, VMs, infrastructure,
then another month
to get databases.
That was reduced
to, maximum, hours.
And I think it's a no-brainer.
Which one would you prefer?
Besides, having
security on board,
you get all the same
sign-off from bank security
team that says, OK,
this is trusted,
and it's been verified.
MICHELLE CASBON: So that brings
up a really important point,
because finance--
and not just finance,
but retail finance--
is such a highly
regulated industry.
What are some of the things
that are most important to you?
What gets you that
sign-off from other teams
to let you move
applications into the cloud?
What was really crucial for you?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
The good thing that I
can share with our audience
from my experience working
in financial sector is that
you need to build trust
with other teams.
You need to prove that you
are a friend to security,
that you are a friend to
operational readiness team,
or whoever is responsible,
to go into production.
You need to build
this relationship
to help them understand
stuff, to promote
that friendship instead of
maybe hostility, and sometimes
positioning yourself
of, oh, we're
doing the modern cutting-edge
technology stuff, versus you
guys are too
conservative, too old, too
concerned about everything.
Help them understand
what you are doing.
Because the truth is
Cloud is the way to go.
The truth is companies are
going there for a reason--
because it's better
in so many ways.
It's just a matter of patiently
explaining and sometimes
spending extra
time to help people
understand what you are doing.
And from my experience, that
pays off a hundred times.
You get your sign-offs faster.
You get people up to speed.
And you just spread
the word, spread
the knowledge of the
transformation that's
happening.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
is it fair to say
that many of the challenges have
not been technical in nature--
they've been more
human in nature?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Yeah, I would say so.
It's a bit of both.
Of course, there is a
technical piece of it.
But there is also a human
aspect in transformation.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
I'm very familiar
with that problem.
I think most engineers I spend
a good portion of their time
really tackling the
human issues rather
than the technical challenges.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Again, you
can't have somebody just show
up to a company with a big
picket whiteboard fence
and say like, hey,
let's go Cloud.
And then everyone's
like, oh, that's great.
Let's do it.
It's not going to
work like that, right?
So what would you
say the best piece
of advice that you could pass
on or the things that you found
to be most helpful when
you started this journey
or when this journey was being
started, to say, how do we
get things running?
YURI LITVINOVICH: One of
the advices that I can give
would be to outline the
benefits of the transformation
that you want to
do very clearly.
Make sure you understand
what you want to bring.
And make sure that
people who are
responsible for decision-making
are also on board
and they understand
why you are trying
to do the transformation.
Because it's quite
obvious that many things
about going Cloud
and going Kubernetes,
going all the cool tools like
Anthos, Istio are better.
Show that.
Prove that this is
indeed the case.
That might require a bit of
extra time in building a POC.
But to have something
tangible to say.
And those arguments
are really convincing.
So that would be one.
And one of the other
tips that can be shared
is that, look at the
success of other companies,
success of other people who
did that transformation,
and show that this is real, that
this is something that already
happened, and you are not the
first one who is doing that.
Because Cloud has been
happening for quite a while now,
though it's still very
hot and very exciting.
And there are good examples
of good success stories
of going to the cloud,
using Kubernetes, using
other cool technologies.
So it's already there.
And that makes it easier
for those people who
have funds and make
decisions to make
decisions towards your points.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So to your
first point about maybe taking
some extra time and actually
showing the benefits, have you
found things like
Kubernetes, Istio, Anthos,
all of those a good platform for
maybe setting up either demos
or proving the technology
to help the cause?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Absolutely, absolutely.
We did that within
Scotiabank, within PLATO,
within our customers.
And we showed them
that apart from having
the power of all the
underlying technologies,
it creates this velocity.
It brings more stability
and more resiliency, cost
efficiency, and it's tangible.
It's easy to use.
MICHELLE CASBON: And
so I think velocity
is really key in
highlighting some
of the benefits of
these technologies.
Is there anything
that it's enabled
you to do that you just couldn't
have done before even at a very
slow velocity?
Has it really changed
things for you
fundamentally as
an organization?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Good
question, Michelle.
[CHUCKLES]
MICHELLE CASBON: How has
it changed your life, Yuri?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
I'm still excited.
I'm still excited
about the cloud.
I'm still excited about
the transformation,
though I've been working
for years in that field.
But I still see
new things coming.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I mean,
Kubernetes is great.
But it hasn't made my
commute shorter yet.
YURI LITVINOVICH:
[LAUGHS] I see.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
hasn't it, though?
I mean, if you think about these
large-scale infrastructures
that might be running,
like the train system
might be running on
Cloud, that might actually
make my commute shorter.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Before we know it,
[? Muni ?] might
completely reconstruct
their entire infrastructure,
and then Kubernetes could
be helping us to work faster.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I thought
it was a ridiculous example,
and I was so wrong.
MICHELLE CASBON:
It's inevitable,
Mark. (LAUGHING) Everything
will be running on Kubernetes.
YURI LITVINOVICH: It's
inevitable, but you know what?
First steps of many
scientific breakthroughs--
they always start in labs when
no one knows what's going on,
only just a group of people.
Slowly but surely,
they get rolled out
to real life scenarios.
So once your commute
gets shorter, Mark,
I'm sure you'll know it then.
[LAUGHS] You'll remember this
podcast and the conversation
we had about all the cool
stuff that GCP, Kubernetes,
and other cloud things offer.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, I mean, yeah.
I think there's a
lot of great things
that have been
solved with asking,
you know, hopefully less
ridiculous questions.
But in reality, how
can this technology
be used in a wide
variety of ways?
And I do mean wide.
Because there's so many
different ways to think about,
how does this apply,
and how does this
enable people to make
those differences?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Yeah, if
you think of Kubernetes,
for example, Google has been
running a [? Borg ?] for years
before actually open sourcing
it making it called Kubernetes
to the community.
So pretty much everything at
Google is based on [? Borg. ?]
And you just build
on top of that.
So having that experience
and having all the power
that Google is now, I think
running the same principles
and same kind of platform,
which is container orchestration
platform, is very
promising and can tell you
a lot about this
evolution is happening.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, it is
not unlike the question of,
do you think the people who
developed Java originally
would have ever thought
that, oh, do you use Java?
Because you move
around in this world.
Same with machine learning.
Even if you think it's not part
of your everyday life, it is.
Because it's part of all
the services that you use.
It's not long
before that becomes
the case with Kubernetes.
All right.
Yuri, is there anything else
you would like to share with us
or talk about before we wrap up?
YURI LITVINOVICH: I have
so many things to share.
So hopefully we can
have another time
where we'll continue this
great conversation happening.
MICHELLE CASBON: I think
that would be great.
If you have any things you
would like to plug, maybe
some websites or
blogs that you'd
like the audience to share,
if they'd like to follow up
with you in any capacity?
YURI LITVINOVICH: I would
suggest that you check all
the presentations that were done
by our team on different events
like Cloud Next last
year, this year,
and just follow Scotiabank and
platform organization to find
out about the cool stuff
[? that ?] this is speaking
of [? our. ?] But if you want to
know more about the technology,
just Google that.
MICHELLE CASBON: I have one last
question for you before you go.
So you've moved all of these
applications onto Kubernetes.
Are you doing any machine
learning on Kubernetes yet?
And what tools are
you using to do that?
YURI LITVINOVICH:
Yes, we do have
plans to use that, to
use machine learning,
and run also different fraud
analytics on Kubernetes
and a bunch of other use cases.
So we'll expand the
platform to support that.
MICHELLE CASBON: Oh, fantastic.
Do you already know which
set of tools you will use?
Or are you still
evaluating which
one would be the best fit?
YURI LITVINOVICH: Oh, yeah.
We'll definitely integrate
that with Dataflow.
We will integrate
that with BigQuery
and other analytic tools
that Google offers.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I hear there's
a wonderful little framework
called Kubeflow that's
really good for machine
learning on Kubernetes.
Can you tell us a bit
more about, Michelle?
MICHELLE CASBON: I've also heard
something like that before.
[LAUGHS] So Kubeflow
is a project
that I've been involved with.
And it's specifically
for running
machine learning on Kubernetes.
So I encourage you
to check it out
if it's part of your
roadmap, if it's something
that you think might be useful.
It's Kubernetes native,
and it's fairly simple.
And feel free to reach
out to me if you'd
like more information about it.
YURI LITVINOVICH: Nice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right.
Well, thank you so much,
Yuri, for your time.
And hopefully we will
get to talk again soon.
YURI LITVINOVICH: Thank you.
It's been my pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
And you guys have a great day.
MICHELLE CASBON: Thank
you for joining us, Yuri.
Talk to you later.
YURI LITVINOVICH: Take care.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks so much,
Yuri, for coming in and showing
us exactly why migration
is more than just a
technical situation that you
need to put yourself through.
You also need to look at the
bureaucracy and the people
side of things
and say, hey, this
is why we're doing
this migration,
these are the reasons
it's important,
and kind of putting the
decision-making factors
into that.
Very, very cool stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no,
really great and super
cool to hear this coming
from you and Michelle.
But why don't we get stuck
into our question of the week?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Because I like asking
tough questions.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And I
sometimes like answering them.
MARK MANDEL: You ready?
So, standard Cloud
Shell comes with a lot
of really great tools
like Go and kubectl
and all the other things
that I really enjoy.
But sometimes I want to have
other things available to me.
Or maybe I'm working
on a project that's
something like Helm or Terraform
or FFmpeg or ImageMagick
or maybe a whole
host of other things
that may or may not be
included in Cloud Shell.
They may actually be there.
I'm not sure.
But if there's
something that I don't
have having Cloud
Shell by default
but I want to add,
how can I do that?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, Cloud
Shell-- and I think
we've talked about this over
the past couple of weeks.
It's just this cool, little
ephemeral environment
that you get when you
create your GCP account.
And it's a great way that you
can go in and, like you said,
it's got all the built-in
things, especially G Cloud.
So you can run those commands,
and you're good to go.
But it's also the
pseudo-temporary, right?
Like, environment
changes won't persist.
So if you install Terraform
and then you come back later,
Terraform might be gone.
So it's not really
a great consistent
way to install those
things unless you'd
like to run those install
commands every time.
You probably don't.
[CHIMES]
So we have a very, very cool
way that you can actually
take your Cloud
Shell environment
and spin it up
using a Docker image
that you can build yourself.
And it pretty much
involves two steps.
The first step is to
create the Docker image
of which you need to include.
So you want Terraform and Helm.
You can just create
your Docker file,
include the steps to
install Terraform and Helm,
and then go ahead
and build that image.
Then you push it up to
the Container Registry.
And in Cloud Shell, you can
go to the environment settings
and just choose
that container right
from the Container Registry.
And then Cloud Shell will boot
into using that container.
So if you have a long,
complicated setup process,
or even if you just
want a few extra tools,
you can quickly, quickly
put that image together
and then boot from that.
And you have everything
you need to go.
MARK MANDEL: I
actually just realized
that means that I could boot
up Cloud Shell inside Cloud
Shell [? right in ?] my Docker
file, inside Cloud Shell,
build my Docker image,
push my Docker image,
and then restart Cloud
Shell in the other image.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You
can use Cloud Shell
to build a Cloud Shell image.
And that is some very
"Inception"-level stuff right
there.
MARK MANDEL: Turtles
all the way down.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
All the way down.
MARK MANDEL: Or
containers, really.
[CANNED LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Containers all the way down.
If there's not a GIF
of that somewhere--
MARK MANDEL: There must be.
Send it to us.
Somebody, send it to us.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: (LAUGHING) OK.
Well, in the meantime, Mark,
what are you going to be up to?
MARK MANDEL: Pretty
much the same
as we have for the
last few episodes.
So I'll be in Tokyo Next, coming
up around the end of the month.
Super looking forward to that.
Then I'll also be
at the Open Source
in Gaming event happening right
before the North America Open
Source Summit, which I'll
also be attending as well.
So, pretty much similar stuff
as always, gaming open source,
Kubernetes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's
almost like you have
specialties that you focus on.
MARK MANDEL: Almost.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Almost.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Almost there.
MARK MANDEL: Almost.
And yourself?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, and my specialty,
creating a lot of
fun little content,
moving around a little bit
to work with some customers.
One of the series that
we're working on right now
is called "This Week in Cloud."
So every Monday, we ship out
a little two-minute-ish video
that talks about some of
the latest news posts.
And I think it's a cool way
to maybe start your week off
and see some
announcements that you
might think are really cool.
So definitely check that out
on the Google Cloud Platform
channel.
I'm going to be working
a little bit with that
and many other series
that I'm looking forward
to talking about once
they get launched
over the next couple of weeks.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
I will definitely check
out "This Week in Cloud."
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Awesome to hear.
And I hope everybody
out there-- let
us know if you think there's
other things that you
think are useful.
But it's another great way to
stay on top of some very, very
cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Well, awesome.
Well, Mark, thank you
so much for joining me,
at least for the beginning and
end of the podcast this week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: [LAUGHS]
Yes, thank you, Mark,
for helping me out here.
And of course, thanks
to Michelle and Yuri
for that awesome interview.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, thanks, everyone,
for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]